so this is something i think about uh  fairly often i consider it maybe the  worst things  i've ever done i was very young about 13  years old and  i was snorkeling in florida on a family  vacation and out on a coral reef  i found a gold wing i snorkeled down  picked it up  and as i came to shore i noticed a woman  looking  in the water for something and when i  went by her she asked if i had found  a ring and i told her no and walked away  as i've gotten older i've reflected on  that moment many times  and realized i had the opportunity to  really make somebody's stay  and instead i chose a very selfish pass  that  actually didn't benefit me much in any  way  and this is something i've pretty much  held to myself  but i think about it almost weekly and  if i could go back and do one thing it  would be to give that woman  huge  you